Lui c’est Jean-Claude Duss.
Et elle c’est Nabilla.
À les regarder comme ça, trop de choses
les opposent, et on ne miserait pas un centime
sur l’hypothèse qu’ils finissent ensemble.
Et pourtant, en fait, ils sont véritablement
faits l’un pour l’autre.
Vous êtes sur 1000 idées de culture générale,
la chaîne qui parle du meilleur de la pensée
sans vous prendre la tête.
Bonjour, je suis Romain, le créateur du site
1000 idées de culture générale et coauteur
du manuel du même nom.
Pour vous expliquer pourquoi Jean-Claude Duss,
un des personnages principaux de la série
de films Les Bronzés, et Nabilla, une icône
de la téléréalité française, sont le
couple idéal, je vais m’appuyer sur la
conception de l’amour de Schopenhauer.
Schopenhauer, c’est un philosophe allemand
de la première moitié du 19ème siècle.
Il est surtout connu pour son gros livre Le
monde comme volonté et comme représentation,
à la fin duquel il a élaboré une théorie
de l’amour, ce qu’il appelle la « métaphysique
de l’amour ».
Grâce à cette théorie, je vais vous expliquer,
toujours en 3 points, pourquoi Jean-Claude
Dus et Nabilla sont faits l’un pour l’autre.
La première raison pour laquelle Jean-Claude
Dus et Nabilla sont faits l’un pour l’autre,
c’est que le sentiment amoureux n’existe
pas.
Petit, chauve, pauvre, vieux et anticharismatique,
Jean-Claude Dus a pourtant tous les défauts
qui sont susceptibles de dégoûter Nabilla
et de la faire fuir.
Nabilla ne pourrait jamais tomber amoureuse
d’un homme comme ça.
Mais Schopenhauer nous explique que ça n’est
pas important, parce que l’amour, au sens
de l’amour avec un grand A, ce sentiment
d’attachement très intense, eh bien il
n’existe tout simplement pas.
La seule chose qui existe, pour Schopenhauer,
c’est ce qu’il appelle l’instinct sexuel.
Peu importe que Jean-Claude Dus dégoûte
Nabilla (l’inverse n’étant très probablement
pas vrai), parce qu’ils sont tous les deux
dotés, en tant qu’êtres humains, d’un
instinct sexuel qui doit les porter l’un
vers l’autre.
Schopenhauer affirme donc que la passion n’est
que l’expression de la pulsion sexuelle.
C’est la procréation qui est le seul but
véritable de toute passion amoureuse, car
ce que recherchent les amants, c’est fusionner
concrètement, et de demeurer dans cette forme.
La force qui doit attirer Jean-Claude Dus
et Nabilla l’un vers l’autre est particulièrement
puissante pour une raison précise.
La deuxième raison pour laquelle Jean-Claude
Dus et Nabilla sont faits l’un pour l’autre,
c’est qu’ils ne sont en réalité que
les jouets de l’espèce.
Quand Jean-Claude Dus multiplie les tentatives
(toutes malheureuses) pour séduire des femmes,
il pense qu’il le fait pour son propre plaisir,
mais il ne fait que ce pour quoi il est programmé
par l’espèce.
Pour Schopenhauer, l’instinct sexuel revient
en dernière instance à la volonté de vivre.
C’est une des manifestations de son fameux
concept de la volonté, qui est l’élan
essentiel de toute vie.
Ainsi, le but véritable et fondamental de
tout amour, ça n’est ni l’épanouissement
d’un sentiment, ni le plaisir sexuel, mais
la la naissance d’un nouvel être.
Jean-Claude Dus et Nabilla sont en fait les
jouets de l’espèce : ils ignorent la force
qui les anime, ils croient faire ce qu’ils
veulent, désirer par eux-mêmes, mais ils
ne font que travailler, à leur toute petite
échelle, à la perpétuation de l’humanité.
La passion amoureuse sert donc la perpétuation
de l’humanité, et c’est ça qui explique
son importance pour les individus et l’ampleur
des moyens qui lui sont consacrés.
Mais bon, ça ne suffit pas encore à dire
que Jean-Claude Dus est l’homme parfait
pour Nabilla.
Ce qui fait de Jean-Claude Dus et de Nabilla
le couple idéal, c’est que l’espèce
fait en sorte que les contraires s’attirent.
Prenez Jean-Claude Dus : il est petit, maigre,
blond, il a les yeux bleus.
Prenez Nabilla : elle est grande, brune, elle
a des formes, et elle a les yeux couleur noisette.
Eh bien, pour Schopenhauer, ces énormes différences
font de Jean-Claude Dus et de Nabilla le couple
parfait, parce qu’elles vont permettre à
l’espèce de corriger les défauts individuels
par compensation.
En clair, l’espèce ne se contente pas de
se perpétuer, elle veut aussi s’améliorer
!
Il y a donc pour Schopenhauer un eugénisme
naturel qui s’exprime dans la reproduction
de l’espèce humaine : au fur et à mesure
qu’elle se perpétue, l’être humain tend
vers un individu parfait et homogène.
Ainsi, la sélection du partenaire ne s’opère
pas par une évaluation de sa beauté dans
l’absolu.
En pratique, l’individu serait surtout susceptible
de tomber amoureux d’une personne pourvue
des avantages physiques que lui ne possède
pas.
C’est ce qui explique que les hommes de
petite taille, par exemple, recherchent les
femmes grandes, les blonds aiment les brunes,
etc.
Schopenhauer écrit joliment que « Les deux
personnes doivent se neutraliser mutuellement
comme l’acide et l’alcali pour former
un sel neutre.
»
C’est beau… mais c’est probablement
faux !
En résumé, Jean-Claude Dus et Nabilla sont
faits l’un pour l’autre parce qu’ils
ont des caractéristiques physiques opposées
qui, en se croisant, permettraient à l’espèce
humaine de s’améliorer.
Alors bien sûr, la thèse de Schopenhauer
est complètement fantaisiste (notamment l’idée
de l’attirance des contraires), mais elle
a l’intérêt de rappeler l’enjeu de la
passion amoureuse est plus important qu’il
n’y paraît.
Elle permet aussi d’expliquer la disproportion
entre, d’une part, les efforts et la gravité
qui sont affectés à la passion amoureuse,
et, d’autre part, son caractère éphémère
et individuel.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo, mettez un pouce
bleu et abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour être
prévenu de la sortie de la prochaine.
Pour lire ma synthèse de l’idée de Schopenhauer
sur le site 1000 idées de culture générale,
voire pour pour lire La métaphysique de l’amour
de Schopenhauer, les liens sont dans la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser des commentaires.
Enfin, pour recevoir les dernières idées
de culture générale synthétisées dans
le format le plus clair possible, vous pouvez
vous inscrire à la newsletter en laissant
votre adresse e-mail sur le site.
Je suis Romain et sous étiez sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.